hello and welcome to a new edition
of las vegas nao in spanish cheers to
natalia bad sound as you can see
i'm not in the studio today and i
have something very special prepared for you
i'm here outside research
world it's the new mega resort  which is
being built and opened rather
here in south las vegas on las vegas
boulevard the first in over a
decade so obviously it had to be
we just write down everything they have to
offer over 3500 rooms three
different hotels nine pools this
more than 100 thousand square feet of casino
and many more things as you can see they
have lcd screens all around
their property and a lot to offer
including a lot of
hispanic artists world known
artists like katy perry child
miley cyrus they have some indian sun
in its grand opening is this Thursday today
June 24 at 11 pm
but the grand opening of the
opening celebration with a presentation by a
thousand  hey cyrus they will close the streets they will have
fireworks and a lot of other
things well before I say goodbye
I also want to tell you about an
event that is coming here to las
vegas and it is not an event it is a great
concert by pitbull
michelle tree of fire dale dale  and go and
watch it on september 18 you can
buy your tickets friday
june 25 which is tomorrow so you already have a
lot of things to do this week
you can buy your pitbull tickets
you can see resorts see las vegas' which
opens its doors like  I mentioned it to you
at 11 pm or on Thursday so that's as
far as I get to your segment of las
vegas' I swim in Spanish thank you very much
for tuning in see you next
week